How to start your targeted resume.
First, select the job
that interests you, and
a corresponding job description.
Before starting a targeted resume,
you want to make sure you have a strong
understanding of the position and
what the employer is looking for.
This requires looking at big and
small scale themes and
patterns within the job description.
When reading a posting,
I like to ask myself questions like,
what are the core features of this job?
What keywords are used?
Are any technical skills highlighted?
Any soft skills mention?
Finally, you'll want to
think about your audience.
To the best of your ability answer the
questions, who will be interviewing you?
What are they looking for that's
not written on the job description?
What do I need to consider about
the organizational culture to construct
my resume?
Did you come up with any
additional questions?
Add them to the forum.